all right here we go no it's more Evan
from Arkansas tight beard yo it up Bo
and Brandon I got some relationship
advice for you boys basically you know
I've been getting in with this girl
she's a little bit older than me I'm a
I'm a young cat I'm about 21 and you
know he's a few years older than me
thinks she's four years older than me
but anyway you know the issue is and
where I need advice is this girl said
female has a few kiddos on deck okay you
know I'm talking three kiddos different
ages and a couple different daddies if
you know what I'm saying
oh yeah and you know God's Judith our
Juice I'm not trying to have three kids
yeah I'm not trusting you father three
guys make messages stop pursuing it give
up on her before you know I become baby
daddy number four
I think order you know you think I gotta
stick it out and become all Ryan I can't
dude here's the thing if she has three
kids bro she ain't stopping that womb
ain't stopping that's her thing yeah
that's that she got you know she really
has that things like a damn that ovaries
like a pitching machine bro you know
that thing's gonna keep throwing zygotes
down the spout daddy yeah I mean I think
you could try to get the coolest baby
out of her you know if you want to make
it like a competition with other local
men in the area I mean I think this
alley cat version of Wolverine should be
happy that he found a girl [ __ ] handsome
guy where's he from
yeah bro Arkansas lot of beautiful and
not a lot of single women in Arkansas
they lock them down there dude they lock
them
yeah shout out to the Razorbacks dude
shoutout to Norman Robinson remember him
I can't from motel 6 or what's that T
not that no I'm thinking of two
different people thinking of the coach
for the Arkansas Razorback I'm trying to
think of yeah I'm trying to get along
Richardson I don't know why don't you
google norm Richardson for me who's the
most famous guy to come out of Arkansas
build my bags
no I'm thought yeah for sure Billy
Clinton and then your boy right there
Norman
oh that's right no that ain't no maybe I
bought that urban gentleman to the right
in the red shirt who is that Nolan
Richardson that's him Razorback thing oh
he's the basketball coach hey all right
dude would you give the inmate the pitch
late a little lady does here he's either
a maid on the new set of sting the King
[Music]
the king nothing
[Music]